well joining us now to discuss this
further is retired Air Vice Marshall
Sean Bell hi again Sean it's really
interesting isn't it the Polish
president uh meeting uh Western leaders
in London today certainly they've
increased their defense spending
significantly in the last few weeks uh
and understandably Eastern European
countries are a lot more worried about
this war than perhaps Western European
countries absolutely but it is
interesting why the Polish leader Doda
is seemingly at the Forefront of all
this he was visiting Rishi ostensibly to
talk about the support to Ukraine
conflict but it's recently that was
following a visit to the NATO SEC
General uh stolenberg where he was
looking at how do you bolster the
defense on the Eastern flank of NATO as
well but all of this is the Russian
invasion of Ukraine was just not
anticipated by the west and there's lots
of NATO countries NATO was a bit in the
doldrums a lot of countries were not
paying their way suddenly this invasions
on their doorstep and they desperately
need to find ways not just to increase
defense spending but to create credible
military capability let's look at Poland
in particular they're looking at the
geography of the place now if the war
Putin's invaded Ukraine but it's pretty
clear that his ultimate ambition is to
restore the Soviet Union and if we look
on a map clearly we've got Belarus here
which is already in Putin's pocket if
he's invaded the Ukraine depending on
how the outcome of that comes the next
um countries on the front line are
Estonia off the top there Latvia
Lithuania and then Poland and so it's no
great surprise that the opponents had a
massive increase in defense spending but
it's also really interested in how you
change that translate that money into
credible deterrence military capability
and that's the challenge these
diplomatic efforts will continue once he
leaves the UK I think on the 20th to the
22nd of this month President Biden's
visiting Poland all of that is trying to
increase focus on how Poland enhances
its uh deterrence capability okay let's
move to the war on the ground now tell
us uh the latest in terms of the latest
missile strikes that have hit Ukraine in
the last 24 hours and of course you know
this this latest offensive which we have
been anticipating by all again accounts
has begun yeah another 32 missiles that
were fired across the Ukraine and
Ukraine claims they've shot down half of
them they seem to be targeting leviv and
denipro across the country but the real
story is the intensity of fighting
massively increased as you say this
offensive which we've been anticipating
the main focus of that offensive has
been around the donbass region it's been
around back move which we've been
talking about for some time down by your
feet there uh cremina and and north of
that but it's worth remembering it's
1200 kilometers of front line here
Russian will be pushing away at all
trying to find any probe any defenses
the scale is phenomenal though Ben
Wallace at events Minister um talking
the other day said that about 97 of the
available Russian military was actually
deployed that they'd taken about a 40
hit in terms of combat Effectiveness
because they were suffering the Russians
were suffering World War One levels of
attrition just shows the scant disregard
they have for their soldiers but also
they seem to have lost about two-thirds
of the available tanks have either been
destroyed or are no longer available
which is probably why Putin was pushing
so hard to get his industry to produce
more the real chance for Ukraine
throughout all this is trying to weather
this storm they do not want to get
trapped into a war of attrition which is
something they would struggle uh to win
they've got to make some decisions at
time do you fight or do you withdraw
gracefully raise the fights another day
volada they're fighting stoically and
some of these pictures are actually part
of the Russian withdrawal because the
Russians sent in this part of their
Elite Naval forces to fight uh to try
and take balodar and they've been
thoroughly decimated and they're
retreating in their droves the Russian
offensive is on its way for Austria
fighting is increasing dramatically it's
going to be a very difficult next few
weeks but almost certainly will prove
decisive to the outcome of the war yeah
it certainly feels like we've reached a
very tense moment Sean thanks again